-Looking good, bud.
Happy Thanksgiving.
-Thanks, man.
-Thank you for being here.
-I'm a little offended.
I just realized --
Like, I have a stylist lady.
And she gives me suits --
no big deal -- to put on.
It's stretchy.
-Oh. That's kind of fun.
-It's a stretchy fabric.
-Is it fun?
-Uh, no. I'm offended by it.
-You are?
-She knows that I was gonna
overindulge at Thanksgiving,
and so --
-So she did that on purpose.
-Mm-hmm.
-By the way,
how'd you like the parade?
You're in the parade this year.
-Yeah, it was so fun.
I didn't -- Yeah, I was in
the Macy's Day Parade.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
I had no idea that it was
as big of a thing as it was.
-Oh, it's a giant deal.
-It was huge.
When they asked me,
they were like,
"You want to be in
the Macy's Day Parade?"
I'm like, "What am I?
A beauty queen?
No, I don't want to be
in a parade."
I was with my dad
when they asked me,
and he's like, "You're
definitely not a beauty queen."
-Thanks, Dad.
-He's here, actually, today.
He was like -- Not here for me.
He's here for Seinfeld.
And --
[ Laughter ]
He's like, "Bring out Bruce!
Enough of you."
But, yeah, it's a huge deal.
50 million people
watch the parade.
-Yeah, it's a giant deal.
-It's a giant thing.
Like, "Workaholics,"
which was my show,
I think, on our biggest episode,
like 3 1/2 million people
watched that.
So this might be the
biggest thing I've ever done.
-Yeah.
-The parade.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm peaking on the float, baby.
-Where are you from?
And where is your dad from?
-Omaha, Nebraska.
My family's from Nebraska,
Midwest, yeah.
-And how do they celebrate
Thanksgiving in the city?
Is that fun for them
or they don't like it?
-Well, it's weird being in
New York,
because, normally,
we're in the Midwest.
But we have, like,
a whole big Thanksgiving dinner
planned at a steak house.
And that was a mistake,
'cause, immediately,
my father was like,
"Oh, you're telling me
New York City cooks better
steaks than Omaha, Nebraska?"
-You're like,
"Alright, calm down, Dad."
-They're gonna be fine.
This is one of the
biggest cities in the world.
They can handle a steak.
He's like,
"I'll be the judge of that."
-Yeah. Oh, my gosh.
Hey, I know you're doing
a lot of things.
I want to talk about
"Bumper in Berlin."
But you just finished a film
with Adam Sandler,
who is a good friend
of our show.
We love Adam Sandler.
-Me too.
-What a great guy.
-The best.
-Yeah.
-I did this movie.
It's called "The Out-Laws."
It'll come out in --
sometime next year on Netflix.
And he produced it,
I starred in it,
and we produced it together.
And he's just an all-time great.
-Did you ever do your
impression of him to him?
-No, because my impression is,
like, offensive.
[ Laughter ]
-It is?
-Yeah.
It's not a good im--
I'm not a good impression--
You're a good impressionist.
My impression is just,
like, the noises he makes.
You know, that...
[ Speaks gibberish ]
No words.
-Yeah, you don't want to do that
in front of him.
-Unh-unh.
-Yeah. Alright.
-[ Speaks gibberish ]
I'm gonna need another one.
-Yeah, yeah.
-So...
-So you didn't do that.
-Yeah.
-But where did you meet Adam?
-I met him like years ago.
The first time I met him,
I was like 19 or 20,
and I was working the door at
the Hollywood Improv
comedy club.
And he came with
a group of friends,
and they were gonna go to
this cigar lounge next door.
And I think I was, like,
staring at him just too --
just wide-eyed, just like,
"Ga-ga-ga-ga-ga."
So he's like, "Don't murder me."
-Yeah.
-"Do you want to come
smoke a cigar with us?"
So I freaked out.
I was like, "Of course I'll go."
And then I awkwardly started --
I asked him.
I was like,
"Did you remember that?"
He's like, "No."
And why would he?
Because I was just
some strange kid who was like...
[ Coughs ]
...who's never smoked a cigar in
his life, just choking it down.
"Play it cool.
You might be in a
'Grown Ups' movie."
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
-[ Speaks gibberish ]
-Can we talk about
"Bumper in Berlin"?
-Please.
-Congrats.
This focuses on your character,
Bumper, from "Pitch Perfect."
And I --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-I had heard that Loki
was an inspiration for this.
-Yeah, from the Marvel movies.
No joke.
-How?
-Elizabeth Banks
was the producer of
the "Pitch Perfect" movies,
and she was like,
"It's cool that
they made the villain
the spin-off TV show" for Loki.
-Yeah.
-And, so, I'm the villain of
the "Bumper" franchise.
-But there are a few nods to
"Pitch Perfect" in this --
-Yeah, we drop a
couple Easter eggs on 'em.
-One of them is the cup song.
-Oh, yeah.
-Which is legendary.
-It's a wildly famous song.
-It's the biggest thing ever.
I mean, did you remember
how to do it?
-No, I had to watch, like,
a YouTube tutorial
to try to remember.
-Yeah.
But I nailed it
in the show, so...
-Yeah, you kind of did, yeah.
-Uh-huh.
-Do you impress family members?
Like, "Hey,
I'll do the cup thing."
-No, all of my family --
they will do it for me.
-Really?
-Yeah.
And they're like, "I bet
you can't do it as well as me."
Like, my little cousins.
And I'm like,
"I bet you're right.
You're 14.
This is all you have
in your life.
I got a life, girl."
-You upped your game.
You did it with a beer stein.
-I did, yeah.
-Yeah.
-So eat it, Anna Kendrick.
-No. No, no.
That's not what I'm saying.
-No, I'm coming for you, Anna!
-That's not what I'm saying.
-I'm coming for you!
-What I'm saying is,
we always have a beer stein.
-Oh, no!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Could you do it?
Would you get nervous?
Could you do it?
You don't have to do it.
-Yeah, no, I'll -- I'll do it.
And there's no possible way
I'll mess it up at all.
-Wow! That was nice slow moving
of the gourds.
-Yeah. You got to start
with it upside down.
This is a pro tip.
-Oh.
-Okay, so...
[ Laughs ]
-I'm so excited about this.
-Watch this.
There's no way
I'm gonna mess it up.
♪ When I'm gone ♪
♪ You're gonna miss me
when I'm gone ♪
by my talk ♪
♪ You're gonna miss me
by my walk, oh ♪
♪ You're gonna miss me when I'm
gone ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Oh! That is how you do it right
there, ladies and gentlemen!
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here is Adam DeVine in
"Bumper in Berlin."
Take a look at this.
-What if we turn this little
concert into a little riff-off?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ German accent ] Of course
you're challenging me
to a riff-off.
You Americans -- you are
obsessed with your riff-offs.
-Wiff-off?
-Yeah, a riff-off.
-It's a riff-off.
-Wiff-off.
-Riff-off.
-You said "Riff-off,"
I said, "Riff-off."
-Okay.
-And I would love to be
a part of the riff-off,
but, unfortunately,
the a cappella by-laws
clearly state a quorum of
a cappella peers
must be present for a
riff-off to be legally binding.
So it's sad, yeah.
-It's actually not sad. Nein.
-Yeah! Nein.
-Nein.
-Adam DeVine, everyone.
All six episodes of
"Bumper in Berlin"
are streaming
right now on Peacock.